We talked a moment ago about the background
blob and the fact that it has two holes in
it, which represented the foreground objects.
Let’s look at this more complicated example.
A binary image, large number of blobs, blobs
with holes in them, and then blobs within
holes within the blobs and so on.
If we apply the connectivity analysis we’re
able to label all of these individual blobs.
It doesn’t matter if the blobs are black
or white; they are distinct, coherent regions
of the same colour, and we can compute labels
for them.
And this is the value of the labels of each
of those blobs.
The background blob is number 1, and within
the background there are three top-level objects,
and they are blobs 3, 2 and 6.
We can consider that these blobs are children
of the background.
The foreground objects are children of the
background object.
Now object number 3 has got two holes in it,
and we can consider these holes as children
of blob number 3.
So we’re building up a bit of a family tree
here.
One is the background, it’s got children
2, 3 and 6; 3 has got children 5 and 7; 2
has got one child, which is blob number 4,
and blob 6 has got two children, 8 and 9.
Now 9 is a bit more complicated: it’s a
hole.
Within that hole are two white objects, regions
10 and 11.
So we can build up a family tree of objects—a
blob hierarchy.
Let’s try this out.
I’m going to load the image that we were
just looking at, it’s in the file multiblobs.png
and we can display that just to verify the
image that we’re looking at.
Now I am going to compute a label image as
we did a little time ago.
I use the ilabel function, parse in the image.
We see that nb has got a value of 11: there
are 11 unique blobs in this particular image,
and we will display the label image.
Here we see the label image and we see all
the pixels that belong to blob number 1, all
the pixels here belong to blob number 3.
This blob up here has been labelled 5, this
blob down here has been labelled 10, and so
on.
Now we’ll use again the iblobs function
that we used in a previous segment, and I’m
going to parse in the original image, and
the result is a vector of blob objects, or
region feature objects.
And we see that there are 11 objects here.
There’s some pretty interesting information
that we see in the attributes of these individual
objects.
In particular, we have an attribute which
is the parent attribute.
So here, for instance, we can see that blob
number 2 has got as its parent blob number
1.
Blob number 1 is the large blob, which is
the background.
If we go and look at the information for blob
number 1 we’ll see that its colour is 0,
it’s a black blob, and we see that it’s
got a massive area so it’s clearly a background
blob.
We also see that its touchflag is set to 1,
and that means that it’s a blob that touches
the edge of the image, and it’s the only
blob that does so.
So we can see again the blob number 2, its
parent is blob number 1.
We can also see that blob number 3 has parent
blob number 1, and blob number 6 has as its
parent blob number 1.
Clearly we can see that blob number 3 has
got two blobs within it, and we can see that
blob number 5 has as a parent blob number
3, and so does blob number 7.
The situation is quite complex for blob number
6.
We can see that blob number 6 has got two
children and they are blob number 8—its
parent is blob 6—and blob number 9—its
parent is also 6.
Now
blob 9 has got two children of its own, and
they are blobs 10 and 11.
So we’re able to build up, if you like,
a family tree—a hierarchy of blobs.
At the top we have the background blob, then
we have the three white blobs, blobs 2, 3
and 6, and each of those have children.
We can represent this information, this relationship
between the blobs, as a hierarchy or a family
tree diagram, and we can represent it quite
clearly and powerfully in a graphical representation.